-Welcome back to the show.
-Oh, my gosh, in person.
-And it's great
to see you in person.
-Yes, in the flesh.
-Thank you so much for --
You helped us out on Zoom.
And then, we actually did --
-Well, I didn't help you.
-You did, you --
-I just was there once.
-No -- well, that --
that's helping our show,
so I appreciate that.
Thank you so much
for doing that.
We also did a great bit together
based off of "WandaVision,"
and that was one of
our best bits
that we've ever done
on the show.
Congrats on "WandaVision,"
by the way.
Since I talked to you --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was so great.
-It's so funny.
-It was fantastic.
It got nominated for
like 20 Emmy nominations.
And I was like, "Oh, my gosh."
And, of course, it was the first
kind of Emmys back where
everyone just kind of came back.
What was that like for you,
that experience of having
an award show
and everyone around?
-It was wei--
I mean, it was very surprising.
No one --
No one does a Marvel job
and thinks that you're going to
get nominated for something.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah -- but you did.
You crushed it.
-But we did.
And then we actually
got to celebrate together
for the first time at the Emmys
because we wrapped during COVID.
And I wish -- I wish
that everyone was together,
like, department heads
and everything.
But it was really special
getting to be there
and celebrate our show among,
like, you know,
like, really serious things.
-Yeah.
-We just had a good time.
-Well, it was so good
and different and creative
that you had to be
applauded for that.
It was just so fun to watch.
And obviously, we'll talk about
"Doctor Strange."
But congrats on that.
You nailed it.
"WandaVision" was so good.
-Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I was happy for you.
But you have --
you have a new project
coming out
that I'm excited for
because I have kids.
You're writing
a children's book.
You wrote one.
-Yes, my husband and I
wrote a children's book,
which I didn't know
I was gonna talk about tonight,
but how great.
-Yeah, you can talk about it,
yeah.
I figure, why not?
-Why not?
It comes out the end of June,
and --
-"Hattie Harmony."
She's a worry detective.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
And this was a project
that we came up with
during COVID and lockdown.
-A lot of ideas
came out of that.
-Yeah, and trying to figure out
what positive stuff to put out
in the world and how to affect
kids in a positive way.
And I love talking about
my feelings in therapy.
[ Laughter ]
-So, yeah --
-So, she's a worry detective,
and she helps her friends at
school identify their feelings.
And then she has a toolkit,
and she gives them tools
to help deal with their worries
and their anxieties.
And it's a book series
I'm really excited about.
-Oh, so you have a second one?
-We will, yeah.
-Oh, really?
-Next year.
-Congratulations!
I love -- Hattie Harmony
is a great --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-That's a cute name.
-Isn't she cute? I know.
That's my husband.
He's very clever.
-And Hattie and catty.
I love it, yeah.
You know, I was reading up
on you before this interview
just to see
if there's anything else
that we haven't talked about,
and I saw that you got
your real estate license
before your career took off.
-I did.
-In New York City?
-While I was in college.
-Really?
-Yeah, I just wanted a summer
job that wasn't at a restaurant?
-You couldn't -- why?
You couldn't work
at a restaurant?
-I just -- you know, I --
I think I'm really patient
with people,
but I don't know
if I actually would've been able
to deal with that every day.
I feel like
"the customer's always right"
isn't the most fair thing
in the world.
-Yeah, there's some customers
that aren't right.
-They're really not right.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, they're not right.
Yeah, treat people with respect.
Yeah, calm down.
-So, I felt real estate --
I liked -- whatever.
I just, like -- it was easy.
I mean, I just --
Getting the license wasn't easy.
That was actually annoying.
But --
-What do you have to do
for a real-estate license?
-You just take classes.
And I didn't, like, sell things.
I worked for someone who did.
-Did you go to apartment
showings?
-Yes.
-You go like,
"Why don't you come take a look
at the kitchen?
It's really spacious."
-And I, like, went in
and, like, turned lights on.
That's, like,
a really big part of my job.
-Wow, nailed it.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Wow.
Isn't that unbelievable?
-But I would, like,
be booking these appointments,
and I just moved to New York.
I was 19 years old.
And I'd be booking
people's appointments,
and I'd come up with street
names that I didn't --
I didn't know how to pronounce.
And there is a street
that is very familiar
to me now...
-Like Houston? Or --
-Well, that one I mess up now
after living in New York
for eight years.
-You're like, "Oh,
it's on 'Hue-ston' Street."
-No, it was Stuyvesant.
-Stuyvesant.
-Yeah, so, I was making
an appointment.
I was like,
"Our client wants to see, like,
46 'Stew-vee-san' Street."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
Stuyvesant you made --
-"Stew-vee-san."
-"Stew-vee-san"?
-Yeah.
-Stuy-town?
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't --
wasn't familiar with it yet.
-That's so perfect.
That's fantastic.
-But no one told me
when I was doing it.
They all were just silent
while I was on the phone.
-"Stew-vee-san"?
-And they didn't correct me.
And then they all just laughed.
-You could jack the prices up
if you lived in --
[ Laughter ]
-I know. In Stuy-town.
"Stew-vee-san" Town.
-"Stew-vee-san."
[ Laughter ]
It sounds so French.
It's so cool.
-Yeah.
-We went --
So they didn't like that at all?
It didn't take off?
-No, it's just a voicemail, and
I was just made fun of after.
-"Stew-vee-san" -- I love that!
I'm always gonna
call it that from now on.
I remember learning
what SoHo was.
I was like,
"Oh, SoHo, that's so cool."
It just means South of Houston.
-South of Houston.
Yeah, everything.
Dumbo, every -- it's all --
-Yeah, I didn't know what
any of that stuff meant.
-Which is cool.
-Yes.
-There is a coolness.
-We made it cool.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. NoMad.
-North of Madison.
-Sure.
-Yeah.
-I think I just learned that.
-Oh, is that right?
-Sure.
-All right.
"Stew-vee-san."
-"Stew-vee-san," NoMad.
-[ French accent ]
We're learning from each other.
Let's talk about
"Doctor Strange."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Normal voice ]
"Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness."
Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Big, big, big movie
this weekend.
Go see it IMAX if you can.
I know you just had
the big premiere in L.A.
-Yes.
-How did that go?
-It was really amazing.
It was --
It's amazing to be in front of
people clapping and screaming.
It's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-You miss that, right?
-I'm really shallow.
I really need it.
-So do I.
Please, I need it more than you.
-But it was --
it was amazing to have
a premiere in front of fans.
I don't watch the --
I didn't watch it.
I haven't seen it.
-You don't watch yourself.
-No, I do watch my stuff.
I just decided
I can't watch these Marvel
movies at a premiere anymore.
-Why?
-Well, every time,
I just watch it,
and I look around me,
and I'm like,
"Well, it's our first flop,"
like, every time.
I just think,
"It's our first flop."
-You think you --
-I saw "Avengers: Endgame,"
and I looked around me, and I
said, "Is this our first flop?"
-"Avengers: Endgame"
is one of the biggest movies
in the history of the world.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And you were like, "Here we go.
We got our first flop."
-I was like, "I don't know.
I don't know about this one."
-"No one's gonna watch
this 'Avengers' thing."
-Yeah. And so, I just decided
I don't want to put myself
through that experience again.
-Oh, it is so --
-So I'll see it at some point.
-It is so not a flop.
And you are getting
amazing reviews, by the way.
You just pop.
You're stunning in this thing.
-I'm a popper.
-You do. You pop.
You come out.
I mean --
Do you read the reviews
or you go,
"I can't get that involved,"
either?
-I see them
when they're sent to me.
Michael Waldron, who wrote it,
sent me a clip of --
Just a segment of one,
and it was such an absurd quote,
that I just told him that, like,
"You're mean, and you're lying,"
and then he sent me the article.
And I went to the article,
and the guy's name was Mick.
And I was like,
"Michael, what a bad alias."
-Oh. You though Michael --
he was Mick.
-"Yeah, okay, Michael."
-Wonder who this "Mick" guy is.
-Where do you live?
In "Stew-vee-san?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, please.
-"I can see you."
"Yeah, I know names, buddy."
No, I say Mick is a cool name.
There --
There's a theory online --
Of course, no spoilers.
I don't want to tell anyone
anything.
-No spoilers.
-Never.
But there's some goodies
in this one.
Yeah, there's some cameos,
maybe?
-Maybe.
I was hardly there.
-You can't say anything, yeah.
-It was just me and a
greenscreen and no other actors.
-Just plug your ears a little
bit and close your eyes.
-Sure.
But do you want to tell them?
-No, I'm just gonna say
that there are cameos.
-Oh, yes.
Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure.
-I wouldn't say who it is.
But then, there's theories
online that say maybe
your character in this film
ends up being the villain.
-Yes, I've heard about this.
-I've seen the film.
I can't -- this is me acting.
This is my poker face.
-Well, you know,
I don't think of any character
I play as a villain
or a bad guy or a good guy.
-Of course not.
We love Elizabeth Olsen.
-No, we just --
I love my characters.
-Oh, okay.
-You know, I want to --
I'm their advocate.
I defend them.
-Okay.
-I just played an axe murderer.
[ Laughter ]
And I love her,
and I think she's fabulous.
-Wow, wow!
All right, so --
-Coming to you in fall.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Bring the whole family!
Not in this one.
Well, congrats on everything.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Elizabeth Olsen
and Benedict Cumberbatch in
"Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness."
Take a look at this.
-What do you know about
the multiverse?
-The multiverse.
Vis had his theories.
He believed it was real
and...dangerous.
-Well, he was right about both.
We found a girl who can somehow
travel across it,
but she's being pursued.
-Pursued by who?
-Some kind of demon,
one that covets her power
for itself.
We've taken her to Kamar-Taj,
and we've got our defenses,
but we could use an Avenger.
-There are other Avengers.
-Yeah, but given the choice
between the archer
with the Mohawk and several
bug-themed crime fighters,
or one of the most powerful
magic wielders on the planet,
it's an easy call.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
Elizabeth Olsen, everybody.
"Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness"
opens in theaters and IMAX
this Friday.